Okay Moron.
Addition to key ins in particular.
Today we're talking about Cyclo addition,
addition to make rings.
So we'll talk some more about epoxides
then owes analysis and how asset towels
play a role in ozone analysis.
And then we'll get on,
I hope to transition metal catalin
assists hydrogenation and polymers
polymerization.
So we're talking and remember
it reaction without canes,
the reagents are called electrophilic,
but their nuclear fillic as well.
And we've talked about these and at
the end last time we were talking about
epoxidation,
which we'll continue with now and then
about ozone analysis and about things
attached to metals, hydrogen attached to
metals and Al groups attached to metals.
Okay. So this is where we
were last time to remember.
There were a whole bunch of arrows we
drew happening all at the same time,
although not in perfect synchrony.
Some were a little more established at
the transition state than others. Now,
after class, uh, I was asked,
wouldn't it have been simpler to
abbreviate arrows is in textbooks.
So you don't draw quite as many
arrows. Uh, I didn't point this out,
but there was a reason
I drew so many arrows.
You might imagine that you
could abbreviate it this
way, right? Which shows,
uh,
the electrons here forming a bond,
the electrons here going to
here to make a double bond.
This double bond coming down
here to make a single bond.
And this bond coming over here,
that accounts for all the electron pairs,
but it doesn't account for them properly.
And the reason it doesn't is some of
them are pie and some of them are sigma.
So it can't be the same electron pair
that's being both pie in the plane of the
ring and sigma or sigma in the plane of
the ring and pie out of the plane of the
ring. So I accounted for the electrons
differently and drawing those, uh,
in drawing those arrows as to
which kind was doing what. Okay.
So at the very end, last time we
were talking about ethylene oxide,
how it was a big item of commerce,
20 million tons a year and $20 billion
because of the importance of ethylene
glycol.
And then we were going to see
how you get ethylene glycol from,
from either base or acid.
Catallo assists with water, uh,
on ethylene oxide.
So let's start with base catallo assists.
Where's it going to attack Bowie?
What do you say?
Where will ooh minus
attack, uh, ethylene oxide.
What kind of reaction is going to happen?
Okay.
Okay, so you want to take
off a proton, is that right?
Huh?
To attack a hydrogen so as
to remove a proton attack.
Sigma Star C h does that with the idea.
Now,
the problem with that is that the ANA
and you get is not at all a good an ion,
right? It's a carbon and iron. The
makes it better than most carbon and ions,
but not that much better.
My guess is it's PKA is
someplace in the forties, right?
Whereas the PKA of o h minus
is, is, or of a water to give.
O h minus is, is, uh, is
16, right? 15 and a half.
So that there's a, a, whatever that is,
that 25 powers of 10 different.
So it's going to be very hard to pull
off a proton. Even though hydroxide,
you're right. Is A, is a strong base,
better as a base than what you'd
expect for its nuclear Felicity.
So how about another possibility if
it's not going to be ch Sigma Star,
what will at attack?
Oh, of course. Ethylene
oxide is an ether, right?
And ethers don't usually
undergo displacement because
it's a bad leaving group.
Right? Oh, minus is not a great
leaving group. Aurel minus.
But this is a special case.
Can you see why
anybody else got an idea? Yeah. Orphaned
high strain, right? We'll,
we'll make that bod week.
So in fact it is a backside attack,
an sn two reaction on the CEO Sigma Star,
right?
Which opens the ring
because of the ring strain
to give that. And now that of
course picks up a proton from water.
The PKS are essentially the same for an
alcohol and water and generates ethylene
glycol. The item of commerce
we were interested in making.
Now suppose we're going to do it with
h plus Ketalysis who's got an idea for
that one?
Rahul,
you've got an idea how,
how's h plus
[inaudible]?
What about
the oxygen,
right? The lone pair on the
oxygen. Okay, so it'll come down,
tack the lone pair on
the oxygen to get this.
And now what do you expect for
the reactivity of this thing?
Rahul will keep us going,
right?
There's still ringing strain and you've
got a much better leaving group now. Oh.
Plus rather than, oh going
to become oh minus. Right?
So now even water can do,
it doesn't have to be hydroxide.
So we've got a great leaving group. Water
comes in and does the trick and again,
we get it. So either acid or
base catallo assists with water.
We'll convert a ethylene
oxide into ethylene glycol.
But there's another possibility for
a nucleophile in this system, right?
Which is this old minus,
right?
So you could imagine it coming down
there and doing the trick and now you get
another o minus that can attack again,
another o minus that could attack again.
So you can get a whole bunch of these ch
two ch, two o ch, two ch two o's strung.
So you can get up poly ether,
there can be, you know,
as few as three to call it poly.
Uh,
although often you'd call
that Alango meaning a few,
but up to 20,000 units or more
can be strung together that way.
And these things are big items in
commerce as solvents among other things.
There are also used in toothpaste and
in a paint ball and lots of different
applications. Okay. And
here's another application.
So you can take the trimmer, right? That's
three of the ch two O is put together.
Okay. And it's been treated with
potassium hydroxide to make the salt.
Right. And you could treat another
one of the alcohols with uh,
one of the agents to convert Oah
and to cl like thigh and chloride.
Right. And get a dichloride.
Can you see what I'm after here?
What kind of reactions I want to do Alan,
right. Sn Two. It's a Williamson
ethers synthesis, right?
R O minus reacting with RCL
to make a cc by or Osi bond.
And what's the product going to be? Right.
That's how he teen crown six has made.
And in fact,
this is what's called an org sin crap.
Org Sin is organic syntheses there.
Uh,
every year they put out
one of these volumes,
I'll pass around so you can look at them,
which have various interesting
preparations that have been,
uh, tested by, um,
by, uh, Kemp proposed by competent
chemists and tested by them,
right? To make sure they work
right. Here's another thing,
send it back the other way.
Okay.
So you can see each of these
has the order of 20 really good,
uh,
careful descriptions with lots of
information about exactly how you do it,
where you get the, where you get the, uh,
starting materials and
lots and lots of footnotes.
So textbooks don't have
time to do this, right? And,
and original publications in the paper
often haven't been carefully checked,
but if you want to see how our
reaction is really carried out,
this is a very good source and it tells
you exactly what faithful yields are,
not ones that have been exaggerated.
Okay. So then one of the orgs didn't,
perhaps is of a 18 crown six.
It's interesting and you
might think about that,
that they used the potassium salt,
right?
The potassium hydroxide was the
one they made the dye and ion with.
You might think why that
might be. Oh, actually,
incidentally, here I have the, uh,
if you click on that,
you will get a, this, uh,
which is the description
of how to make 18 crown six
on the web from org sin.
Okay? So that's how,
that's how we open
ethylene glycol. Now, uh,
notice that if the,
if the epoxide is unsymmetrical
substituted on one side and not the other,
then there are two different
ways of attacking. For
example, in the textbook, uh,
it shows that you could attack the less
substituted or the more substituted and
it says it acid,
the nucleophile generally becomes
attached to the more substituted carbon in
base. The nucleophile generally becomes
attached to the less substituted carbon.
So this is obviously a generality and
one would be interested in seeing precise
data to see just how selective it is.
All right,
so here's an example from the book
where they used a sodium amid.
So in three minuses,
the nucleophile and indeed here with the
anti and attacking it attacks the less
substituted as you would expect that
an sn two and gives a 41% yield of the
product from attacking the
less substituted carbon.
Now do you find that then
convincing in terms of uh,
what in acid you attack one and then base
you attack the other? No. What he say,
why?
Yeah.
Now of course you've been in lab and I
wouldn't be surprised if from time to
time you've been happy with a 41% yield,
right?
So if you really do get 41%,
remember we've talked about one
synthesis where 5% was plenty.
So from a point of view of preparative
being able to make this stuff 41% sounds
pretty good,
but if you're interested,
does it really support that generalization
that with base Catalin sis that is
anti and attacking you attack the less
substituted when you'd want to know what
the other 59% is, if the other 59%
were attacking the other carbon,
that would be bad news for this
generalization. Right? So, uh,
so one has to be careful in reading
textbooks because often references aren't
given right about that 41% so here's,
here's a, a generalization. It
says that, here's, here's the,
the other example with
acid catalin [inaudible].
So it says that when you attack with acid,
indeed the chloride goes more
on the more substituted carbon.
That's what the generalization was.
But notice that the,
that the product ratio is 55% to 45%.
It's not 99 to one.
Right?
And then explains it by saying charge
is the charges on the more substituted
carbon. That is when
you protonate the, Oh,
that bridge is unsymmetrical.
We've talked about that with more
charge on the more substituted carbon.
So that's the one that gets attacked.
That's where the nucleophile ads is.
It says, but notice that this is a
tough thing to generalize or not a very,
a reliable example to generalize with
the 55 to 45 because that ratio is 10 to
the 0.09.
Right?
Which means that the difference
in activation energy for
going one way and going
the other is,
uh,
at room temperature is
0.12 kilocalories per mole.
And you're a sophisticated enough by now
to know that that's nothing, you know,
that's, that's only what, uh, uh,
25th as big as a hydrogen bond.
Right?
So it's true that it gives more of the
more substituted one in this particular
case, but you wouldn't feel very
confident in, in interpreting that.
Okay.
So you might do a calculation to see
what the minimum energy geometry is for
such a protonated at Parkside.
This is not a really high quality a
calculation and it's in the gas phase.
And of course we're solving is,
could make a lot more difference
than 0.12 kilocalories per mole.
But anyhow,
you could look and see where positive
things would like to be or negative things
would like to be on the Vanderwall
surface of this molecule.
So if you look up here at the top,
remarkably enough,
if when you drew this structure,
you'd draw it. Oh, plus, right?
It's a trivalent oxygen.
It's been the o of the three
member during has been protonated.
So you'd draw Oh plus,
but notice that this is the energy of
Proton would have on the surface of that,
right?
It's high near the oxygen,
but it's 120 kilocalories
higher near the hydrogen.
That's the worst place
to put a positive charge.
So it's not what you would draw if you
just put a plus charge on the oxygen.
Right?
So that's the worst place for hope for
h plus it would be the best place for a
negatively charged nucleophile.
So the best thing would be to pull
the proton back off again. Right?
On the other hand,
you could,
if you turn the molecule upside down
from the top right and look at the bottom
of it, you see the two carbons that
could be attacked and at that place,
the energy for the Proton
would be plus 140 there.
It would be plus 141.5
so it doesn't really,
it's true that it's a little bit more
positive near the central part near the
more substituted carbon,
but not very much.
And of course it's
sterically hindered there.
So it seems to be very touchy
to try to interpret this.
But still there are many examples
where it is more dramatic than that.
Uh, here for example, uh, is our,
our cases were from the
textbook where the, uh, uh,
carbon nucleophile does the attack.
Now you notice that when the fennel,
uh, attached to copper attacks, so that,
so the polarization is such as the
fennel is mostly plus a, pardon me,
mostly minus.
So it's the nucleophile although it's
really more complicated cause the coppers
around at the same time,
but notice it,
it attacks backside and
it gives a 98% yield.
So that's the kind of thing when you see
it in the book that you can say, Aha,
that's really something 55 45 is not
the basis for confident interpretation.
98% is more like it.
Okay.
Or in this other example where it's
85 to eight attack at one comp at one
position versus the other with base
Catalin [inaudible] attacking is the
generalization had said at the more sub
at the less substituted carpet to give
the 85% product.
So there are plenty of examples
that support this generalization,
but it's not always reliable and it's
important to be critical in looking at the
evidence that people provide to
support their generalizations. Okay.
So that one shows stereo specificity.
The other one shows Riggio
specif specificity and much
more impressive than that.
55, 45 example, 85 to eight,
much more practical for synthesis
purposes and much more convincing for
interpretation purposes. Okay. So that,
that much for the epoxides uh,
now on to Ozu analysis,
which takes us into other examples of,
of Cyclo audition.
Of course, forming the UPPP oxide
is a three member of drinks.
So it is a cyclo audition
at forums a ring.
But ozone is more interesting
because it's three atoms, right?
So we can imagine this
shift of electron payers,
right?
Perhaps happening all at the same
time to make a five membered ring.
Right.
And on the left is the train,
the arrangement of those atoms in the
transition state as calculated by quantum
mechanics.
All right,
so we could look at the, at the, uh, uh,
at the motion along the reaction.
Coordinate both face on here.
Uh,
the side view as I said,
and also the end view and noticed that
the o three is bent so that the central
oxygen is not as near the,
at carbon's being attacked as
the terminal oxygens are. Okay.
So now watch and we'll watch it move.
So the oxygen's moved down,
the carbons move up and formed the bond.
We'll reverse it and go back
and forth several times.
So you can see it's another one of these
cases where it looks like the attacking
group is rotating down toward the
carbon is the carbon moves up.
Yeah.
Okay. So notice everything is
happening at the same time.
It's not that you form one
bond and then the other bond.
Yeah.
Okay.
So let's look at the orbitals that are
involved in making two new bonds at the
same time. So there must be two
electron pairs that are involved. Okay,
so there we have the Lumo
on o three and the Homo on,
uh, on ethylene. And you see,
remember that that central
carbon decentral oxygen up
on top is getting into the
act.
It's back behind the screen.
So you'll see the two reds of the lube
oil on top or in position to make good
overlap. And then give this, this, uh,
orbital at the transition stage,
which is the homo,
those overlapping with one
another to form, to be bonding.
That's one electron pair.
So that would account for one bond.
But by the same token, you have the Lumo
of the owl keyed on the bottom right,
interacting with the Homo
of o three up on top,
and those overlap well and give a,
the homo minus one.
So another pair of electrons get
stabilized as these atoms come together.
So two electron pairs get stabilized
to bonds are formed. Okay,
now this is psycholo edition of our
Lilly one three dipole to alkenes.
There are other examples besides ozone.
Now a one three dipole
is the thing like ozone.
You may remember that
in the third lecture,
way back at the beginning of the fall,
we talked about drawing
valence structures for ozone.
And the fact that it's not the lowest
energy structure is not a three membered
ring, but an open form, right? And
the interesting thing about this,
when you draw a Lewis structures,
you can't draw a structure that doesn't
have charges or free radicals on the
Adams, right? So those examples are shown
there. So these things are called one,
three dipoles,
there three atoms that row and all of the
structures you can draw or dive polar.
But those,
that's not the only example.
And here on the exam
from several years ago,
I asked a question saying heavy learned
that the elderly Pi system of o three
remember Al Lilies means three P orbitals
overlapping in a row. That's Ella, Lily.
And that's obviously the case with ozone.
So having learned that Al Lilly Pi System
of ozone forms to bonds at wants to,
an alkene has shown bottom right,
left there.
One might think to try the same thing
with the apparently analogous Boron
compound. I've not actually
confidence at that molecule exists,
but it might explain in terms of the
orbitals involved why this might not work.
It looks like the same thing.
You have a one three dipole on the right
and we draw air curved arrows to make
the two new bonds.
We have one three dipole on the left and
we draw curved arrows to make the new
bonds. But why wouldn't the
one on the right work? Okay,
let's try to do a
theoretical analysis of that.
So here's ozone viewed from the top.
Now if we rotate it,
the central carbon at the central oxygen
at the top back to look to see the p
orbitals, we see that there are
three p orbitals in a row, right?
An Aloe Lake system, uh, so,
and the lowest energy Pi orbital.
Then we'll have them all overlapping
favorably with one another.
That will be psy one the
lowest energy Pi orbital.
It has no anti-bonding node and the
middle atomic orbital will be largest it.
We can choose the size of the P
orbitals. On this of the three, right?
There's an advantage to making the one
that the sum of their squares has to be
one. Why do you call that
condition? I remember
that's normalization, right? That the PR,
the electron has to be somewhere with a
probability. Total probability of one.
So the sum of the squares has to be one,
but they don't have to be the same size.
Cemetery would suggest that the two
ends should be the same size. Right?
But the one in the middle
could be smaller or bigger.
And I say that it's a little bit bigger.
Why should it be bigger? Why should you,
why do you get advantage by
having the one in the middle?
Big compared to the ones at the end. If
there some, some of their squares is,
his lip is fixed.
What you want to get is bonding overlap,
right?
So the bigger the orbitals,
the more overlap.
What's special about the one in the
middle? Why do you want to make it bigger,
Lauren?
It's overlaps twice,
right? Good. Okay,
so then the next one has a node in
the middle that doesn't surprise you.
And the highest one has two nodes.
Now I'm confused by this because
it may,
in starting with three atomic orbitals
and making three molecular orbitals,
you have to use up to three
atomic orbitals. So they have to,
if you have more in one place,
there has to be less than someplace else.
Obviously there's none on
the middle oxygen in the,
in the one that has no node,
that means that the others have to have
more of that and less of what's on the
end. It doesn't appear
that way in this picture.
It doesn't appear that the central
one is big, but in fact it has to be,
and I think this is a,
this is some,
a artifact of the particular
contour that's been chosen and I,
I can't really explain it,
but in general,
the bonding one is as the
favorable inside one is,
is favorable as it can be big
in the middle. The, the, uh,
the second one with a node in
the middle is obviously 50,
50 on the two ends and the top one
will be big in the middle to be as anti
bonding as it can be. It's a, you know,
when they were good, they were very,
very good. And when they were
bad, they were horrid. Okay?
That's the way it works out.
Okay?
So those are the three or molecular
herbals we're going to be dealing with,
okay? Now if you take another ally
league system, like C H Two B, h,
c h to the one we were,
uh, talking about, right?
We can look at,
it's a p orbitals and there's
psy one and there's side too.
And there's cy three. And this one
does indeed show biggest in the middle.
So that's satisfying.
Of course,
Boron is less electronegative than carbon,
right?
Less nuclear charge.
So you'd expect the lowest orbital not
to have so much of it and the highest
orbital to have a lot of the
less favorable orbital. Okay?
And now if we look at a third example,
carbon eel oxide,
which you notice is, is uh,
uh, carbon eel compound,
h two CEO Formaldehyde
with an extra oxygen on it.
And that turns out also to be a one
three dipole to be bent in the structure
shown.
And now it's not symmetrical end to end.
So we see the same orbitals but
they're distorted. This one, uh,
this one looks mostly like
the c double bond o Pie,
but a little bit of the, of the,
uh, oxygen on the end, right?
That one has a node in it and that one
is mostly the anti-bonding Pi Star of
carbon steel with a little bit of
the oxygen on the end. Now, uh,
why should it be that way?
We'll notice that the carbon is much
closer to the central oxygen than the
central oxygen is to the terminal oxygen,
right?
So the big interaction will be
between carbon in the central oxygen.
So we could,
we could first look at the interaction
between carbon in the central oxygen and
then look at the interaction
of that whatever we get
from that with the terminal
oxygen,
because the,
we'll look at the strongest interaction
first and then at the weaker one.
So when we, uh, uh,
that says what I just said and it will
make a Pi and Pi star out of that.
And now we're going to mix p o the,
the terminal oxygen with Pi and Pi Star.
Okay.
And we see it's closer to CW
to the Pi than to the Pi Star.
So we'll get three new ones
that look like that. Okay.
There's less mixing at the
top, more mixing at the
bottom, a better energy match.
But cy one still looks mostly like
the lower energy would Pi CEO,
the Pi Star looks mostly like Pi,
star of CEO,
and this one looks mostly like
the terminal oxygen. Okay.
That's just to show that
the orbitals are reasonable.
So that's big on Pi and a little
bit of the terminal oxygen.
That's that one. Then you have one
that's mostly the terminal oxygen,
and then you have one
that's mostly Pi Star.
Good.
Now let's look at how many Pi
electrons we put in to these systems.
So we have to count electrons.
So here we have three oxygens there,
sigma bonds,
but also unpaired electrons that are
sigma in the plane of the three o's.
Right?
And there are also then if we count
up electrons on the terminal oxygen's,
there's one more electron on each of the
terminal oxygens and two on the central
oxygen. So they're four
electrons in the PI system,
right? So in these Pi orbitals,
we have to put in four electrons.
Okay? So that's two payers and they go
into the lowest two orbitals of course.
Okay. And the, so the homo
is the middle orbital,
the one with the node,
and the Lumo is the one with two nodes.
Okay.
Now suppose we're going to take
ozone and react it with an alkene.
Okay?
So we bring an alkene up and remember
it touches the two oxygens on the end.
The ones in front,
not the one that's behind the screen.
So that'll make a nice bond,
right? Nice bonding interaction.
So the,
the symmetry matches and we get
stabilization of one pair of electrons.
But if we take the
homo, uh, of the Alkene,
it mixes with the Lumo of the ozone.
So another pair of electrons
get stabilized that we
make to bonds at the same
time and make the five membered ring.
So that's fine.
And it's, and as I said here, don't
worry about the oxygen in the center.
It doesn't overlap because it's
behind the screen. Now let's look, um,
let's go over to look at the carbon
eel oxide and count its electron.
So that's the sigma electrons.
And in the pie there's one from carbon,
uh, one from oxygen and two from
the terminal oxygen. So again,
there are four electrons,
which means we're going to
occupy those two. And again,
uh, the homo is going to be the
one with one node and the Lumo,
the one with two nodes.
And when we bring the alkene up,
it's going to do it's trick. Okay?
So that's fine too. That'll form.
That'll form a five membered ring.
Now let's look at the other one.
The one that has boron in the center.
Okay, so that one made two bonds,
okay? Now the one with Boron in the
center has just those two Pi electrons.
The Boron is not contributing anything,
okay?
So we have only two Pi electrons and we
occupy only the lowest of these orbitals.
So it's the homo and the
middle one is the Lumo.
And now you see when you bring alkene in,
it doesn't do the same thing because
the homo of the alkene looks just like
this.
And they're repulsive with one another,
and the Lubo of the alkene
looks pretty much like this.
So it's homo with Homo Lumo with
Lumo to give overlap and nothing gets
stabilized. It's repulsive. Okay,
so that one won't do the trick,
right?
There is no alkene homo match with that
Lumo and no alkene Lumo match with that
Homo.
So the ones on the end,
we'll do cyclo auditions and
give a five membered ring,
but that one with Boron in the middle
won't because of how many Pi electrons it
has.
So you can't make two bond simultaneously
for Cyclo addition to the Alkene of
that hypothetical compound.
Are there any questions about
that? Let's see. Monitor ugly,
complicated,
then review it.
Okay, so let's look at what happens
then in the process of Ozu analysis.
Incidentally,
that name,
the license part means a
loosening or a breaking apart.
It seems a funny name, doesn't
it? For a Cyclo edition,
which is clearly bringing things together,
but you'll see in a second what
happens. It's pretty neat. Okay,
so we bring an alkene in and and make
those two new bonds by shifting the
orbitals as waste as we just
were describing. So we get
this five membered ring,
but this isn't so stable. Why
is it not stable? Boy Tech,
you've got an idea.
Yeah,
those oxygen,
two oxygen in a row of peroxide is bad.
Three oxygens in a row must be even worse.
What?
Remember what makes two oxygens in a
row bad hello in pairs repelling it.
In this case we've got this compound
is called a Moloz denied if you have to
give it a name,
but it's unstable because of the
mixing of these homos with one another.
The unshared pairs, so that's
really bad. So it breaks apart.
Of course it could break
apart just the way it formed,
but in fact it breaks
apart a different way. It,
it draws these curved arrows,
right?
Which is the same kind of
thing we formed it with,
but we're breaking different
bonds from the one we formed.
We formed this bond and this bond and
now we're breaking this bond and this
bond.
Okay.
So it undergoes a reverse of the
previous process assess to give that.
So that's an Aldehyde plus this Carbonell
oxide that we saw in just the previous
slide,
a one three dipole.
But the carbon oxide could do a cycle
of addition so it could reverse this,
but it wouldn't because the
product would be unstable.
Do you see how to reverse it and make
the product more stable where you don't
have three oxygens in a row?
Anybody got an idea?
How did you make the Cyclo audition?
Go of the one three dipole to the double
bond and not have three oxygens in a
row.
Elisa
[inaudible],
uh, use what you just formed
instead of the three hours.
I'm not quite sure what you mean.
Do reacts the Ch two, Huh? We to see
h two with, oh, in other words,
you could turn that molecule over and now
do the Cyclo audition and you get this
for which only has two oxygens in a row.
And that's what,
that's the product that you actually
get by reacting. Uh, oh three with,
with the, uh, alkene
right now, this, this, uh,
[inaudible] denied as it's called.
Remember that first one with three options
in a row was called a mole was and I,
this one's called an ohs. Denied.
That's not so fantastically important,
but it's what they call them.
This is called this.
I call here a double asset towel.
Now,
an asset towel is a carbon
that has two oxygens on it,
right to ether oxygens.
So you've got that one,
but you also have that one. So
it's a double asset towel, right?
And as you can hydro hydrolyze
asset towels with acid.
So we're going to go through and figure
out the mechanism of that as another
practice in using curved arrows.
So Natalie, I want you to start
us with its acid catalyzed.
So what's going to be the very first step?
Okay,
Proton will attack and unshared
pair on the oxygen. Good. Okay.
Now what's our goal?
You know,
there'll be lots of different
things we can do as we go along,
but as we try to formulate a mechanism,
it's important to remember what
kind of thing we're trying to do.
And the kind of thing we're aiming toward
is to remove Aro and replace it with
Aho.
That's the goal of the first step.
So you've got to start it.
Well, we've take a proton,
come down and attack the
unshared pair and we got that.
Now what's the next step?
Not only can you help us some more
positive change.
Now the positive charge,
remember,
makes a homo makes
orbitals be high in energy,
but the positive charge is not, uh, is
not an orbital. It's just the charge.
What's the, what the, what
particular electrons would be or,
or what particular vacant orbital would
that be? We want a low vacant orbital.
The plus charge will lower
orbitals. What's the low
orbital that we're going for?
Yeah,
there is any Pi electrons in this?
No double bonds.
Sigma Star. So the Coo Sigma Star. Okay.
Right. So we can do this. Have you
ever seen a reaction like that before
where a leaving group leaves,
leaves a cad ion?
Anybody seen a reaction like
that, Alex? That's right.
That's right.
Sn One reaction right where
the leaving group leaves.
We made it a good leaving group by
putting the positive charge on there.
Now, uh, uh,
that's a primary cad ion,
right?
That doesn't look like a very
good candidate for sn one. Alex,
do you see any reason why sn one
might be feasible? Why that cat eye?
It might be better than you would imagine.
I could tell you a reason why it's bad.
Oxygen is electron withdrawing,
right? High nuclear charge. So
it tends not to let cat I form.
It pulls electrons. Right?
Why is that a good cat?
Anybody else got a suggestion?
Helen Jones or the Ade or
part? Debbie. The electrons.
The electrons.
The adjacent oxygen gets stabilized,
right?
The unshared pair on the
oxygen get stabilized.
We can draw that resident structure.
So it is an unusually stable cad ion.
Not because c plus a stable,
but because that low vacant orbital
stabilizes the oxygen electrons next door.
Okay, so we have, we got that cat on
and now we have it's hydrolysis, right?
So water is going to get into the act
form a new bond and we have this and we've
done what we wanted to do here. We're move
aro and replace it with oil. With with,
Ooh, of course we replaced it with
h two o but that's no problem.
We can lose the Proton to some,
uh, to another water molecule.
So we've done the first step here.
Hey,
we have what's called a half asset
towel, a hemi acid towel. Remember,
an asset towel had to our own
groups attached to ch two.
Now we only have one. The
other is Ohi, Hemi acid towel.
Now what do we call what?
This whole process here, if
you had to give it a name,
a mechanistic name, what
would you call it, Alex?
Sn One.
Okay,
so that's an sn one reaction.
And now the second goal is
to remove the second aro,
then a proton from o h and then we're
going to generate a double bond here.
We're going to get CEO double bond.
Okay,
so again, we have acid ketalysis. Where
are we going to attack for this purpose,
Roy? Right? Attack
we, that's the one we want to lose. So
we protonate there, right? Next step,
Roy,
right?
Lucasarts and other sn one kind of
thing, right? Where we make the cad ion.
And now what's the last step?
If we want to lose a pro
marijuana lose age too
from here, we just do it. Right.
Okay.
And what would you call that process?
The one that went from here to here,
if you had to give it a mechanistic name,
Roy.
That's evil,
right? Fort Formation of the cat.
So the process is he won. Okay,
so that did it.
What we've done,
the overall transformation is to take
water plus and asset towel acid ketalysis
and get a carbon eel plus to our ohs,
right?
The one here and the one up there.
So we started with the asset towel and
water and the water comes across and we
get to alcohols and the Carbon Eel,
right?
Just by the sn one and
[inaudible] mechanisms that
we just worked through. Okay.
So that's how he,
that's how you hydrolyze an asset towel.
And here's an asset towel,
right? Ch Two has two o's in it,
so we can hydrolyze it or
we can hydrolyze that one.
We can hydrolyze both the one on the
right and the one on the left and you see
then what we've done. Now you see
the license part, the breaking apart.
What, what was the starting
material? What, where,
where were these carbons
in the starting material?
The very early before we added ozone,
the CC an Alkene,
the CC double bond.
What we've done is break the CC double
bond and make two c o double bonds.
So that's the license part. The
breaking apart. We change a CC,
double bonded to two c o double bonds.
But notice that a biproduct is
one of the byproducts is water.
The other one is hydrogen peroxide,
which is an oxidizing agent,
right?
So it gives two carbon EEOC
compounds and hydrogen peroxide.
But it turns out that hydrogen peroxide
oxidizes aldehydes to carboxylic acids,
right?
So this is a problem.
So you don't just get
the two carbon heals.
You also have something that can react
with the Aldehyde the carbon eel.
So now as the book points out,
you can add any of your books.
We'll give this, uh, what
they're there to post.
Two ways you can cope with this problem.
One is if you want to make the Aldehyde,
put something else in that will react
with the hydrogen peroxide to get rid of
it.
So you use a reducing agent and we'll
talk shortly about oxidizing and reducing
agents, but things like uh,
dimethyl sulfide or zinc,
which destroys the hoh.
So the book now gives examples where
you see you could do this first,
treat it with ozone to get the Ozo died,
then treat it with water,
but with zinc to there in order
to reduce the hydrogen peroxide.
And now you've got the Aldehyde in 93%
that's the kind of yield that's really
convincing. Right? Okay.
Or here's another example where this one
is first Ozen ISED and then when it's
hydrolyzed is treated with the sulfur to
get rid of the hydrogen peroxide and it
gives us 75% yield of this
Aldehyde and also the,
the other one ch, two o from the
other side of the double bond. Okay.
The other possibility is just go with
the flow. If it's going to oxidize,
fine, put in more oxidizing agent. Right?
So there we use the dive methyl sulfide
and their zinc as reducing agents.
But if you add more of more
hydrogen peroxide as has done here,
then you can make the carboxylic acid
and reasonably good yield. Like this one,
for example, 85% yield.
Okay? So that's uh, uh,
that, those are the two
possibilities. With those analysis,
you break the CC double bond,
but the carbons can become either
carbon steels or carboxylic acids.
Now how does that happen?
How does the Aldehyde react with hydrogen
peroxide to give a carboxylic acid?
So let's try another mechanism here.
Derrick, you're going to start us in.
What's going to react with what here?
What's the home?
What's the little minus on the
ozone homo, the minus on the, Oh,
the homo and what's well this via
double like a two at the same time.
Uh, let's suppose we
aren't that sophisticated.
All right then c double bond.
O was the Lumo c double bond o Pi Stars.
A good example. Where would it
attack? Uh, see you, the uh,
take the seat TAC. Let's
see. Okay, so there we go.
That's going to give this. Now, can
you think of a second reaction, Matt?
Let's go to you. Gosh. All right,
well where do we have a homeowner? You
know, hold on. The had apparently. Oh,
okay. So here's the
homo. Where's the Lumo?
Lumo would be the o six sigma star.
Oh.
So we could do an sn two kinds
of reaction, right? Like that.
That's what you had in mind. Okay. And
it's going to form a three membered ring,
right? With two oxygens next to one
another. That's bad. That's not so great,
right?
Cause the oxygen oxygen's a lot of strong
bond and the three member during is
going to be strained.
So that was a reasonable idea.
That's why I wrote it that way. But if
I had written it a different way, uh,
you know, this week, okay? And the
three, remember green is even worse.
So forget that.
So I'll write a different confirmation.
And now this is a neat reaction. Again,
we're going to use sigma star. Oh,
with Oah Levy group. It's a
weak bond. Oh, whoa. Right?
But now we're doing something else.
We're taking the electrons from
ch to be the attacking group.
So it's a,
it's a hydride shift.
And what pushes the hydride away,
what allows it to do that
is the fact that this,
these electrons can go in and form a
very strong CEO double bond at the same
time. Okay? And this will remind
you, if you think about it,
a little bit of another reaction.
We looked at this hydride shift
reminds you of this alcaide shift here.
Remember when you had B minus,
it was possible for these electrons
to displace the O in that.
Remember that's the second step of the
hydro bore ration oxidation process.
Okay? So it's the same
kind of reaction. Okay?
So it's a rearrangement and that
gives the the carboxylic acid.
But of course it also generates hydroxide,
which reacts with the carboxylic acid.
So that's the stable product
is the carboxylase and I.
Okay? So that's, that's why when you add,
when you have hydrogen peroxide there,
the Aldehyde becomes a carboxylic acid.
Now here's the problem for you to work on.
Uh,
try doing the same thing here.
We used base Catallo Isas.
Suppose it were acidic conditions and
you had to do it with the Siddiq Cadalli
basis. Could you draw a mechanism
that gets to the same place?
Of course it would be protonated if
it's a city of rather than basic.
But see if you can put
together a mechanism that's
acid catalyzed that does the
same thing.
Okay.
Now we've been talking about electrify
electrophilic additions to carbon carbon
double bonds.
We talked already last semester about
nuclear Philly condition to see o double
bonds, right? So nucleophile
versus electro file.
But remember that that the addition to
the carbon carbon double bond was both
electrophilic and nuclear Philly.
So it wouldn't be surprising if the
addition to the co double bond is both
nuclear fillic and electrophilic.
So let's just compare it.
Uh, so the nuclear family condition
of methyl lithium carbon eel group,
and we'll discuss this more when we
talking about the chemistry of carbon eel
groups is formally quite different
because you had electro files to alkenes.
But this cs shows you that there's really
quite a similarity. So here on top,
this is the transition state for
the addition of methyl lithium.
So the yellow or orange thing is lithium
and the ch three of course is methyl.
So that's it coming down on
top of Formaldehyde, right?
And that's the transition state.
So what's happening is we're changing
partners here with these electron payers,
right?
Going toward that product,
right? So we start with this methyl
lithium and the car and the carbon eel.
And there we have a homo,
which is the lithium carbon bond,
mostly won't carbon.
That doesn't surprise,
but notice that it's well
set up to interact with the
Pi Star of the carbon eel.
And by the same token,
here's Lumo plus one,
a p orbital on the lithium,
a vacant orbital,
which is well set up to overlap with
the red part of the homo. So again,
there are two electrons that do the
trick homo with Lumo Lumo with Homo,
and you get both things happening at once.
And we'll come back and
talk about that more.
But I just wanted to show you that it's
not a completely different thing from
the addition to alkenes.
Uh,
and now we're ready to
talk about, uh, metals. Uh,
let me just do a little bit
at the beginning and then
we'll go on next time to
talk about more.
So Osmium tetroxide or per manganese is
osmium or manganese minus in the center
of four oxygens. Right? And
notice that that looks like this,
like ozone, these three atoms in a
row above the two of the [inaudible].
So you could,
there's it's homo and it's well set
up to interact with the outcome,
uh, uh, Lumo and there's, it's Lumo,
which is well set up to act with
that Alkene Homo, although I've,
I seem to have messed up
the animation a little bit.
So here we can see it happening,
right?
It gives this osmotic Esther right now
notice it forums to bonds at the same
time.
It's like this one three dipole are cyclo
audition and that's the osmium analog
of that sick lake asset towel
that we looked at before.
So we can imagine water coming in and
breaking it apart to give a double bond to
o h groups.
So the product then from that Osmania
Ester of hydrolysis is the dial.
So you can make a carbon carbon double
bond break this Pi bond and put two o h
is on.
So Osmium tetroxide is a very good a
reagent for giving that in high yield.
In other respects,
it's not such a great reagent.
And we'll talk about that next time.